when someone presents you with their
scripts and they say I need you to help
me make it better what are you looking
for what what are the main things
they're gonna stand out to you first
usually very often when I we're not when
I'm in that position with someone who's
giving me a script and says you know do
I want it you know what can I do to make
it better my question is why do you want
to tell the story and very often when I
do that I am tap until unplug and tap
whatever a-hole well of stuff that's not
in the script like very often people
will say I want to tell the story
because if this doesn't happen to me and
I was younger right there's the story
there's some stuff let's put that in the
script so very often I think the first
step for me is always always always why
do you want to tell the story and if
they say well to make money and to you
know be the next superhero movie then
I'll say cool okay let's look at
structure and it's fix it with the
structure and the characters and stuff
as long as I know why you want to tell
the story but then if I dig a little bit
deeper there might be something else
okay well so is the reason you want to
tell the story because you feel a little
bit insecure and actually need a claim
and money to survive in the world okay
what happens if your villain has got
that same problem in your superhero
movie whew now suddenly it's alive you
know and then so so you can unpack a lot
just by asking someone while they want
to tell the story and then you try and
apply that to the script and then make
it a bit better so that's the first
thing I'd say and then I'm looking for
resonance when I'm reading the script
I'm looking for you know is this fresh
is this original is this authentic to
your to the story you're trying to tell
and can you make it more authentic by
drawing from your memory well or from
other you know any other sources to make
it stronger and then you know you ask
all the normal questions like who's your
main character what does he want why do
I care about him you know
all those kind of regular screenwriting
questions which anyone can ask but for
me what's more interesting is why do you
want to tell the story and it's funny
that people will write a whole feature
film through without knowing that I also
don't know I mean I wrote my coming out
of Suburbia script and only when I did a
rewrite with another writer that had
come up like her
jeepers my main characters fear is that
he doesn't want to leave super because
he's scared of the world out there
because I'm scared of the world I'm
scared of success and you know all of
these things and that's my characters
problem and I was like ah and then
suddenly everything changed so it's a
bit of getting involved in yourself that
can get really strong then suddenly the
story becomes very clear and you know
that's what it is
that's what it's about so yeah I would
say that's my first and then like you
know is the formatting correct that's
another story you know basic formatting
errors in scripts as though it's like it
yeah that can be a problem from people
who haven't read enough scripts but I
understand you know they even they're
using final draft but then I understand
even if you're using file rough doesn't
mean your formatting is necessary
correct it can stall you know you can
override certain things so yeah so yeah
from the sublime to you know why do you
want to tell the story to the most
mundane which is is it formatted
correctly these are the errors often in
first-time scripts present anything that
stayed with you from your time in the UK
something a professor said to you yeah
that's you apply oh there's two there's
two statements so two things that I
learned in when I was in the UK the one
thing in studying the one was drama is
conflict and I remember they told me
that and at the time I was really
against conflict and I'm still against
conflict in terms of physical you know
fighting for some you know for something
because you weren't something and
somebody else want something and you
fight about or you know that kind of
conflict and I remember like underlining
it angrily in there I scratched it out
angrily then I realized afterwards okay
they kinda right it is about conflict
like everything there needs to be
something so for example you know if the
story is about you and I and then this
glass of water and we both want the
water we have a story you know as an
actor you can do that you can act it you
can perform it you can find strategies
around how to get the water and that's
your strategy and that's my structure
you pit them against each other
so I think there is conflict but it
might not be physical actual fighting
conflict they can be strategies that you
can apply and and so I think that drama
is
I've come around to the to believe that
so that was the one thing that just kind
of stuck with me because my first
reaction to it as the student was like
now it's not and then I was like okay
okay ya know what's the conflict in the
scene I need to know what why am i
watching this and there needs to be
something it can be very simple it can
be that someone's got a piece of I don't
know sticky paper on his face and you
can't get rid of it and that there's a
conflict between him and the sticky
paper but you know there's conflict and
I'm gonna watch until the conflict is
resolved and that's what I what is
interesting and human beings tend to run
towards gunfire and away from tears and
what that is about us but we want
conflict we seem to want it so yeah and
then the other thing that stayed with me
was use the white of the page somebody
said that use the white of the page and
what they meant was I didn't know it
took me a long time to figure this out
but it was that the layout of your
script and how you use your action
particularly your action you know so if
you write you instead of just writing a
block of action you break it up into
sections so that the script looks
beautiful it looks like a script but it
also reads like the movie so in other
words you use your enter button as like
a like a cut almost you use long
descriptive passages if it's a long
lingering shot in your mind you short
sharp sentences if it's short sharp
sentences if it's a you know kind of an
action scene you can have like
explosions of dialogue here off of
action here and there so use the white
of the page is great because it starts
to talk about the craft of screenwriting
and talks about the voice of the writer
so the more scripts you read the more I
start to see oh this is the voice of the
right and that's about the white of the
page because it's it's basically like a
poem
it's a beautiful it's a visual document
as well it's not just a novel you know
you can't say use the white of a page
for a novel because novels is just
written they just text but if you think
about it with a script it's even where
the dialogue is placed and how much
dialogue there is is it kind of gives
you a feeling it gives you a turn now
turn allottee is actually what
moviemaking is all about is you know
what is the tone of this film
what is it Reza and get come back
to resonance how do you create the tone
of a movie in a script well that's by
using the white of the page and by
trying to get the voice of your of your
writing and the tone into the script and
that that's like high maths high math
you know that's like advanced advanced
screenwriting is if you can learn to use
the white of the page and you know
you're doing something really well
you